would you call this film a passion
project yes yeah sure
why was it such a passion project for
the both of you I mean because I I've
never done a role like this I thought it
was such a great story I wanted to work
with carne and dumb I was like let's go
movie is is a difficult or unusual
enough story that we had to do it for
not a lot of money we had to shoot it
really quickly
it was very down and dirty in that
respect and that's a challenge that's
not for everybody you know we really had
to build our stamina a day after day
every day of shooting it was it was hard
we spent all my scrapping tell us hungry
I'm scared I'm gonna find something
Jason
something
I mean the physical transformation is
what as so many people are gonna say
whoa - as well that's kind of the first
thing they see what did it take to
transform into here what all did you we
just did we did some makeup mist and
then we just kind of we did one at my
house which was fantastic cuz when we do
when it becomes in your home and you're
just kind of there it's very gritty
we're running after the cam yes and very
you feel like you're in films yeah yeah
you're playing it's very it's very
playable yeah
yeah what happens becomes authentic so
then it just becomes that oh this is
very real to me I'm in this skin I'm in
this in this person I'm not standing on
the outside trying to make this happen
what did they call the only
transformation when they saw you were a
bit scared yes Jerry
yeah yeah she's probably she's some
angry and she's defensive and she's on a
mission and she's has a lot of rage but
she also has a lot of pain and heart and
is trying to fix the damage and heal
things knowing what where she's leading
right and I think that's very emotional
and that's but it's a good story - and
the other thing I always say to people
is people like oh my gosh it's gonna be
too frightening or too violent for me
I'm like it's not no really it's a film
that you can handle yeah I agree can
definitely handle the film it's not it's
more it's more like it it's it mirrors
sort of what Nicole probably went
through and playing the role it's like
you're letting a really difficult guest
into your home yeah yeah yeah
where were you when you got the Golden
Globe mm nomination news I just touched
down from Australia I'd landed here
in Los Angeles and I turn my phone on
and there was a beautiful waiter save
that sort of information I was just so
glad because I cited corn this is ours
it's ours together because anyone that's
in after knows that it's you and you're
directed together that does something
it's never and then it's the crew and
writers and everybody so it's a very
shared nomination and a very shared
experience usually comes out Christmas
Day well somebody see Nicole Kidman in
the theater singing at Christmas Day or
do you are you just gonna say no magnet
I want gonna see it on Christmas right
but I'm gonna try and do some Q&A sport
and you know this is the baby we're out
there I'm delivering the baby into the
world
well speaking it you have holiday plans
to you but like holiday traditions in
your house that you do with the family
that live in LA yeah we are yeah you was
doing that light up the houses but we
and we play and we're we're really into
Mike my daughters are really into bingo
right now oh that's fun maybe doing my
mom's yeah because yeah
Kinmen urban urban get me you're welcome
anytime
[Music]